The Department of Justice
has a very serious
and sensitive new investigation
on its hands.
The DOJ now
looking into leaks of classified U.S.
military documents
that were shared on social media.
Some of the materials were marked
top secret.
That's the highest level
of classification.
The leaked documents
covered everything from U.S.
support for Ukraine to key information
about U.S.
allies.
CNN's Kylie Atwood joins us now.
Kylie, what more are we learning?
It sounds as though
these documents are very sensitive.
Yeah.
I mean, as you said,
some of these documents are marked
top secret.
That's the highest level
of classification
in the US intelligence system.
And so obviously it's
really concerning to US officials
who are now
trying to go through these
documents, understand
what exactly is in them.
We still don't know the source of them.
So these documents appeared on
social media sites
over the course of the last few weeks,
and they gained some attention this week.
The first documents
that gained attention
had to do with us support
for the for Ukraine, Ukraine war,
war plans.
And so U.S.
officials were asked
about those documents
and they said that they do appear
to be legitimate U.S. documents.
The other documents
that we have just gone
through in the last 24 hours
or so that have to do with a widespread
number of issues
related to China, really
related to
Israel, related
to the United Arab Emirates.
Those are the documents
that the Pentagon says
that they are still reviewing
at this time.
And so we don't know
if those are all legitimate documents.
But when you talk to US officials
they say that they look like they are.
So this is an incredibly
alarming situation
that's still unfolding in terms
of what kind of damage assessment
the US government will make.
As a result of this leak.
And what are U.S.
officials
telling us about these documents
where they might have come from?
I suppose there's plenty of speculation.
Do they have any best guesses
at this point
or is it
still just too early on
in this investigation?
Well, it is really early on,
but I think it's interesting
to look
at the actual documents themselves
that have appeared on social media,
because what it looks
like is a crinkled up piece of paper
that someone took a picture of.
And they have markings, as I said,
of top secret on some of them.
Some of them have markings of the office
in the Pentagon
that actually advises President Biden.
So these are as close as it gets to,
you know, the highest level of U.S.
secrets. And when you talk to U.S.
officials about these documents,
obviously,
they still say that they're doing
an overall assessment
to see if any of the documents
had been altered
when they were put up
on these social media sites.
But they do say that they do
look legitimate.
And do we think this was
a hacking of some sort?
Could it have been leaked out by U.S.
intelligence partners?
Somebody inside the
intelligence community or
inside the Defense Department, perhaps?
Any sense of that?
Yeah.
I mean, all of those are possibilities.
As I said,
we just don't know the source right now.
But when it comes to US intelligence,
the United States
shares intelligence
with four other countries together.
They are known as the Five Eyes partner.
So it's the U.K., Canada,
the US, Australia and New Zealand.
So those are some of the countries
that would have shared
some of this
highly classified US information.
But when you look at these documents,
some of them have markings
that indicate
that there was information in them
that wasn't
shared with any of those partners,
even those close U.S. partners.
So what
that indicates
is that
if they came all from the same source,
we don't know if they did,
but it appears
that they were all kind of dropped in
similar drops here,
that that would have come
from someone or something
that gained access
to the US intelligence
system and not those of our partners.
But of course,
our partners are just as alarmed
by this as U.S. officials are.
They're doing
their own damage assessments
right now
to try and figure out,
you know,
if any information they shared with
the U.S.
is now leaked into the public eye.
Jim, All right.
Kylie Atwood, thanks so much.
Really appreciate the reporting.
Thanks again.
Let's get some perspective on this.
We're joined now
by retired Lieutenant General Ben Hodges.
A former commander of U.S.
Army Europe.
He's also a senior adviser
at Human Rights First.
General, great to see you.
What's your take on
these leaked intelligence documents
This does not happen very often.
And so when it does happen,
it has to be a big concern,
not only for the U.S.
intelligence community,
but as Kiley
was talking about a few moments ago,
major U.S. allies, major U.S. partners
Yeah, great reporting by Kiley.
Obviously, this is very damaging.
You never want your enemy
to know what you know.
Or how you got it.
So this will reveal the depth
of penetration and a lot of information
that we had.
And, of course, one of the keys
to good
intelligence is being able to share
with other allies, other organizations.
And so this will damage some of the trust
that's necessary to have this good
intelligence sharing.
I expect the investigation
will eventually sort of figure out
where did it come from
or how did they get out.
But it does
it does once again
remind us of the vulnerabilities
we have
and probably some holes in our systems.
I can't count the number of times
I had to go
through online
training about
preventing just this kind of thing.
And so at the end of the day,
it's usually about
training and discipline
Right.
And these
documents are similar
to a batch of classified documents
about Ukraine
that have been circulating online
in recent weeks, which U.S.
officials on Friday morning
confirmed to CNN to be authentic.
Some of the documents,
which include
estimates of Russian casualties
and a list of Western weapons systems
available to Ukraine,
were apparently posted
on social media in March.
Ukraine believes
Russia is behind this purported leak.
What do you think, General?
I mean,
could this jeopardize
Ukrainian forces on the battlefield
How serious is it for
what's happening in Ukraine?
Well, you know,
the Ukrainians, of course,
are super disciplined.
They've always been reluctant
to share information.
We've always known
more about Russian forces than we did
Ukrainian forces.
And so I think they will
they'll have
done an assessment
and figure out what they need to do.
But they're also
the Ukrainians are agile enough
to be able to turn this to advantage.
Perhaps,
you know, having
having information does not.
If you're not able to use it
somehow, it's not necessarily
going to be so damaging.
So I think the Ukrainians
will be
smart enough to figure out
how to address this.
I don't see it as a terrible
change for them.
The biggest damage is under
the trust that we have with
with our allies.
And I want to switch to Ukraine.
Ukraine's energy company
today said that over
1200 Russian
missiles and drones
have been used to attack
the country's infrastructure
utility infrastructure,
saying 43% of its main power
grid has been damaged.
I mean,
I guess we thought about this
as a possibility.
Heading into the cold winter months.
What does this say
about the Russian tactics
during a vulnerable period like
like the winter?
Well, I think
it showed the
desperation of the Russians,
the fact that as many missiles
as they have
launched drones, missiles, rockets,
different types of platforms,
the fact that they really never
could knock Ukraine off the grid.
And Ukrainians,
I'm from Florida
and you know, we're good at recovering
after hurricanes.
The Ukrainians became
very proficient at rapidly reestablishing
their power grid.
And I think that the
I think British intelligence
is reporting that
the frequency
of these attacks by the Russians
is actually beginning to to decrease,
even because they realize
it's a total waste of precious resources
or maybe, you know, they are running low
and they're worried about needing them
for for later.